ja wir wollen anfangen mit ganz
aktuellen bildern von heute morgen in
der kleinstadt mascioli im osten der
krim hat sich heute morgen diese mega
explosion ereignet wie sehen sie unten
eine von vielen explosionen und wir
sehen gleich auch stunden später nämlich
jetzt noch brennt ist hier also vier
stunden später sehen wir den wald dort
in flammen und weitere explosionen die
dort passieren das sind ganz aktuelle
bilder von etwa vor einer stunde wir
sehen hier weiterhin explosion die
stattfinden und diese explosion
natürlich kommen uns ein bisschen
bekannt vor denn vor sechs tagen haben
wir gesehen wie die ukraine
höchstwahrscheinlich niemals offen
eingestanden ein russischen
luftwaffenbasis im vest im westen der
krim angegriffen hat heute morgen hier
explosionen im osten der krems und wir
gucken uns das ganze mal auf der karte
an und sehen wie wichtig das ganze ist
denn wir haben nicht nur in maske
sondern auch im
backhaus heute morgen explosionen und
ich zeichne ich hab mal etwas ein das
hier ist die eisenbahnlinie die aus
russland aus dem echten russland über
die besetzte grimm in richtung besetzter
ukraine geht und hier haben wir heute
morgen die beiden explosionen gehabt das
heißt wir haben zweimal entlang dieser
eisenbahnstrecke ganz in der nähe in
kleinen städten dort die explosion
gehabt und tatsächlich heute morgen
wurde gesagt die karlsbrücke ist für
züge gesperrt der zugverkehr ist erst
mal ausgefallen das heißt auch wenn hier
eigentlich eine umspannwerk und einem
munitionsdepot angegriffen wurden waren
die konsequenzen unter anderem dass der
nachschub für die russische armee in der
süd ukraine damit heute erstmal
unterbrochen wurde das also für die
ukraine ob simonetta steckt oder nicht
parallele explosionen und wir haben sie
in das muster gute nachrichten wir
müssen aber leider auch schlechte
nachrichten zu sprechen kommen und dazu
sehen wir uns die lage im osten des
landes an wir versuchen hier einmal rein
zu fahren und sehen dass hier in der
region donetsk weiterhin russland
versucht vorzustoßen und aus der stadt
so ne da das ist hier an der grenze
haben wir ganz neue bilder die auch uns
als deutsche ganz persönlich betreffen
denn wir haben hier bilder der
russischen armee vom samstag wie sie in
ein großes werk vordringt und dieses
werk ist von einer deutschen firma von
der firma knauf die hier beton
hergestellt hatten auf ein weltweites
unternehmen mit 220 werken auf der
ganzen welt eines dieser werke wurde am
samstag wir sehen uns hier von der
russischen armee eingenommen nach
monaten der kämpfer und wir sehen die
ganze zerstörung und wir gucken uns das
mal an denn wir sehen auch dann gleich
von von drinnen die bilder hier geht man
jetzt in die büros rein
und wir sehen jetzt hier auch das knauf
symbolbild an der wand da ist es das
symbol der deutschen firmen und wir
sehen jetzt wie die russen
wahrscheinlich ja aus ärger über uns
deutsche eine deutsche flagge hier
treten ja haben uns das nochmal an hier
die deutsche flagge liegt auf dem boden
von einem russischen soldaten herunter
geschmissen und jetzt sehen wir gleich
wäre darauf herumgetrampelt und sie weg
tritt vielleicht eine kleine reaktion
darauf dass die russen hier böse sind
dass viele ihrer kameraden von der
deutsche panzerhaubitze 2000 hier
natürlich getötet wurden aus der region
jetzt sehen wir hier wie die russen in
diesen berg sich an den lkws entlang
bewegen noch ganz vorsichtig die wissen
nicht ob da noch ukrainische soldaten
sind aber wir wissen mittlerweile dass
dieses handwerk fest in russischer hand
ist nicht etwa von der regulären
russischen armee erobert sondern von
söldnern der truppe wagner und von
tschetschenischen kämpfern von diesen
kriegsherren da unten herren kadyrov der
natürlich putin loyal und ergebnis dass
also hier die bilder aus dem osten der
ukraine wo wir gesagt haben eine stunde
da die russen weiter vordringen ja zum
schluss vielleicht noch ein bisschen
hoffnung für die ukraine nämlich dass
hier das sind aufnahmen aus der west
ukraine von minen und hinterhalt
geschützten fahrzeugen der amerikaner
max pro heißen die in wir sehen hier
dutzende davon bewegen sich über eine
ukrainische straße um endlich die
soldaten der ukraine sicher von a nach b
zu bewegen die ukraine fragt seit
monaten nach in deutschland ob sie
vielleicht diese fuchs schützenpanzer
haben könnte oder die gepanzerten
fahrzeuge vom typ dingo die bundeswehr
und die bundesregierung vor allem herr
scholz möchte nichts davon abgeben jetzt
gut für die ukraine müssen wieder die
amerikaner einspringen und sie springen
ein und sie geben diese unbewaffneten
fahrzeuge hier mit dem ukrainische
soldaten sich entlang der front bewegen
können wir wissen über 1000 kilometer
front gibt es hier jeden meter den mann
davon ungepanzerte ohne ein fahrzeug
zurück blickt er ist extrem gefährlich
wegen der art wie für die ukraine jetzt
haben sie also die chance sich zumindest
sicher von a nach b zu bewegen nicht tag
deutschlands aber dank der amerikaner
[Musik]